Hey,
what's going on?
Bill Burr is time for the Thursday
afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
and Ahh,
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
Oh needy.
What are you going going to go work out
there you go.
Get on the elliptical.
Do it.
All right.
That was part of our prenuptial
agreement.
Keep it looking good.
It's exactly what it is.
You would never dare.
Try to get a prenuptial agreement with
me.
What are you talking about?
Throwing that out there.
I'm throwing it out there right now.
I'm going to get a post married,
prenuptial postnuptial agreement.
No,
I'm going to get all right.
Mine all mine.
You know I don't even give a shit.
You want all this stuff?
I don't care.
It's a fucking headache.
Songs.
They got enough for a sandwich.
I'm good.
I want every color of izod shirt.
Yeah,
seriously though.
I will.
I will leave you.
There's a certain level that if you
allow it,
if you drop below,
I'm walking his bald,
pasty,
redheaded male,
pushing 50.
Okay.
Don't look at me like I don't have
options.
Woman.
I've been out to the strip malls.
I've seen the looks okay.
You put me in a strip mall near that has
a dentist and a place where they do your
taxes.
Okay.
Fucking hedges.
Whipping around.
Yeah.
She could at least pretend that I'm
still kind of good looking.
Right.
Alright.
Anyways,
what's up everybody?
How are you?
How's your week going?
Is it going well?
It's almost over.
At least the bad part of it is.
Huh?
How about a moment of silence?
How about a good moment of silence for
everybody who's sitting in a fucking
place?
They don't want to be right now.
Huh?
There was your moment and you know what?
That's all you deserve.
Why are you still there?
Stand up.
Push that plastic wheelchair away from
that fucking.
I know you were.
Then what do you do?
Right?
Don't do that.
You need a plan.
Come up with a fucking plan and my
stomach's can be grounded like crazy.
I just,
I just got off of a,
got off of the plane,
had a 7:00
AM flight,
came back from New York.
I went to the,
uh,
it's just an amazing,
a memorial service for Charlie Murphy
yesterday and uh,
I got to tell you this because,
you know,
it's a private ceremony.
Some I can give any details,
but I will tell you this,
you know,
comedians,
we,
a lot of us may die young,
but I will tell you this,
we have great funerals.
It was fucking unbelievable.
It was unbelievable.
They,
a New York legend was sent off by
legends.
It was,
um,
it was incredible.
It was really incredible.
So,
um,
yeah,
still sad though,
obviously still sad,
but he would have been very happy.
I'm like morning to speak for him
anything but like,
uh,
I hope I get sent off that well.
It was A.
Yeah,
there was definitely something else.
So that's quite built.
Bring up something that you're not going
to really give any detail stuff.
Well,
you know,
whatever.
I just,
I just.
So anyways,
so everybody hung out afterwards to like
2:30
in the morning and I had like a 7:00
AM flight and the only way there's two
ways to handle a 7:00
AM flight,
which is going to involve like a fucking
4:30
AM pickup.
All right?
There's only two ways to do it.
You either go to bed,
you know you drink some hot cocoa at
7:00
PM and you figure out how you're going
to get your fucking eight hours.
Whatever you do.
What do people do with your pills?
Is that what you do when you sit fucking
Indian style 40th bed going,
okay.
Oh
what?
Whatever's whatever that meditation shit
is.
All right.
Which I have not done and I'll tell you
the ramifications of that here in a
minute.
Do you either do that or you just stay
out drinking with your friends to like
2:30
in the morning and then you come home,
you get about an hour and a half,
two hours sleep.
You staggered to the fucking airport,
whatever out to the cab.
You go in there and you just do.
The biggest thing is not to nod off at
the gate,
you got to stay awake,
but the lights are on and that type of
shit.
And then once you get to your seat,
that's it.
Then you're out.
You're out.
Let's see,
let's fucking.
And that's a great way to do it because
then you don't have to sit there bored
out of your mind on the flight,
you know,
by the way,
thanks to the person that sent me that
fucking creepy video of that plane crash
in which for some dumb reason,
I'm sitting there watching it,
but the tail section coming off this
plane,
these pilots trying to figure out a
fucking way to try to land it,
which of course you can at that point,
um,
I wasn't surprised that they didn't
invert.
That's always a fun thing.
Half asleep to be watching because you
know,
you're half asleep going like,
wait,
am I on this flight or is this a,
is this a,
should I be feeling that failing?
You know,
they sent me this video and I'm not
getting on this plane.
Well,
you know what,
I got on that Goddamn play.
And I went right to sleep and woke up
like five hours later,
five hours later on a six hour flights.
Perfect.
You know,
they come over,
sir.
Would you like anything?
Would you care to give up my job?
Well,
I go,
yeah.
What do you got?
Well,
we got a mushroom.
We got a Porta Bella mushroom sandwich.
Yeah,
that sounds gross.
What else you got?
I don't even know what the other thing
was.
I thought when she said the mushroom
thing with the other thing,
I thought it was all the same thing.
Goes at all one thing or is that two
things?
She goes,
that's two things.
And I went,
all right.
I,
I don't want anything.
I got a new thing.
I don't eat on planes.
I'm not fucking doing it.
It's just,
it's fucking shit.
Food empty.
And do you have like a fucking five
miles up from the surface of the,
of,
of the earth,
you know,
the only thing you should be eating up
their shit that you shouldn't be like
pringles potato chips and stuff.
Why would you eat those?
And you just sit in there and get big,
just becoming a fat fuck.
So I sort of been doing this thing this
year is,
I'm trying to fucking drop some weight
here,
you know,
even though my dad,
I'm not going to have the fun,
I'm not having the fucking dad bought.
Not having that thing,
you know,
thing where you go to lift up your arms,
your shirt comes up in this.
Just that fucking pork shoulder spilling
out on the side.
That ain't happening to me.
Um,
oh.
Speaking of which.
So,
uh,
you know,
I packed hastily because I went to
Boston first and then in New York and
uh,
so I grabbed a suit and everything and
my shoes.
So I have them for the memorial service
and I forgot to bring dark socks.
All right.
And also I was working out and doing the
elliptical and all that type of stuff.
So I thought it brought enough boxes and
I didn't.
So I was like,
fuck.
So I landed in New York.
I get to the hotel and it's,
you know,
would like in mid town and Shit,
we meaning me and all my fucking
personalities and uh,
so I called me up,
I tell her where I'm at.
I was like,
fuck,
you know,
the car's coming to get me to take me
over to the service,
you know,
I need some,
uh,
underwear.
What should I go?
This is New York.
There's no fucking gaps anywhere.
They're all like downtown a way uptown.
I'm right in the middle.
I don't have time.
And she asked me where I was and she
goes,
I know that.
And it was like,
I guess like a gay neighborhood.
She goes,
go around the corner,
there's up,
there's one of those fucking stores.
So go across the store,
right street,
right.
And there's like,
you know,
the second you see the mannequins,
you know what I mean?
You know that it's,
yeah.
This is like a,
it's a gay store.
It's for gay men.
So I don't give a fuck.
I need underwear,
right.
Gay Men still wear underwear.
So I walk in there and it was just like
Jesus Christ.
There was like cock rings on the fucking
wall,
which by the way,
I thought that was the same is like,
uh,
like when people get their Dick Pierce,
which I still don't know where they do
that.
It's like a navel ring,
but it's on your Dick.
So I thought a cock ring,
you know,
I thought that that was the same thing,
but it wasn't,
it was like a,
a looked like something you'd use in
plumbing,
like a gasket.
Evidently you put that around your Dick
for some reason.
Then what?
You Swivel your hips and it's like,
it's like a Hula hoop for your dick
evidently.
Right.
So I fucking go in the back and the
underwear,
it's like ridiculous.
It was like all these Fred Flintstone,
prince,
you know what I mean?
There was like Atlas Shit.
And then I finally find a pair that was
just all black and on the waistband it
said nasty pig.
So finally just yellow to the dude
behind the counter go,
hey,
you got any like normal,
like mainstream underwear here.
And he's like,
define normal or main street.
And I was like,
well I don't,
it doesn't say nasty pig on the,
on the waistband,
it has material around the ass and when
it does,
it doesn't say fuck my whole on the
back,
you know,
regular,
just underwear,
like hang on,
the fucking comes over there.
And he ended up finding some that would
just wear all black,
you know,
Greg Louganis style.
But they will.
The only size they had was small,
which was fucking hilarious to me
because I was just like,
yeah,
why would you have a medium?
This is like gay guys.
They want to see their boyfriends junk
spilling out the side.
Oh you nasty pig.
So I had the leaves there and the
closest place was fucking Tj Maxx.
Oh my God.
They'll fucking animals.
And half of it was the way they had the
store,
like the way they had the store setup,
it's just like it was so fucked up.
It's like it was like I was in
Manhattan,
the crown jewel of fucking cities in the
United States.
Right.
And the second I walked into fucking Tj
Maxx,
I mean I might as well benefit a fucking
walmart in the middle of nowhere.
And I am talking down to Middle America
and they're Walmart's.
I am talking down to it,
although I'm not the expert,
you know,
those walmarts aren't that bad other
than on black Friday.
Black Friday is the day you don't want
to fucking go down there because that's
like white people,
bloods and crips,
you know,
that's our version of it.
It's flannels and fucking in flip flops,
that's,
that's our bloods and crips and you
don't still want to be there on that
date.
You know,
when they have one Atari for $3,
way in the back of the store and
everybody's just basically going to
trample people.
Like they go into the fucking who
concert Cincinnati way back in the day
there.
I mean,
other than that,
you know,
it's not,
it's not that bad.
A store,
you know,
it's got all kinds of food.
Giant selections.
I've gone in there a bunch of times.
I don't know why I brought that up.
I still knew what the fuck I'm talking
about this point o t j Maxx,
you get the Max for the man above at Tj
Maxx.
So I go in there and it's,
you know,
typical Manhattan fucking store where
it's like half the stores downstairs and
the oldest in is on the ground floor on
the other is like upstairs because they
slammed this little fucking store in
there
and um,
finally find some underwears and I'm
like,
fuck,
I gotta stand in this God damn like
Disneyland level line.
And like,
all right,
they got 12 fucking registers open.
So even though there's like 24 people,
you know,
roughly each one of these cashiers just
knocks out to people and then it's my
turn.
All right,
this shouldn't be this bad.
And it was this woman in front of me.
I don't know what kind of soap she used,
but like I would divorce her.
I swear to God.
Even if she made my heart stop,
I'd be like,
I love you.
I wish nothing for you,
but this fucking soap.
It's a specific soap.
I've smelled it before.
It wasn't,
she didn't smell bad,
she smelled of this soap.
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but it just,
I,
I can't be around it,
but I had to be around someone who's
going to cut me and then they just
walked you through,
you know,
the Disneyland thing where you walk all
the way to the right.
Then you go back to the left,
you know,
zig zag and all the way up.
It just the shit that they had the
impulse buys in everybody.
If they weren't staring at their fucking
phones,
we'll just pick it up.
These things and the more I saw people
picking up this shit,
looking at it like the angrier I was
getting,
like,
why are you picking that up?
You don't need that when you find you
the names of these fucking things.
Okay.
They had this one thing that said I
would thank you from the bottom of my
heart,
but for you,
my heart has no bottom and it was just
framed in this piece of shit frame and
on a white piece of paper,
which is regular font,
like please don't walk away with the
bathroom key,
like the same kind of font.
You would use the data at the gas
station.
They wrote that fucking cheesy heartfelt
message.
And what the fuck was the next one?
Oh,
it was just some sort of like coconut
almonds,
yummy clusters or something was called
that.
And that's how I was able to.
This is like,
this is the demographic I'm in.
Let's,
let's become Fed Fox and talk about how
we love each other.
I don't want to talk about.
So I get the underwear and I fucking get
back to the hotel room.
And I realized in my looking down at
everybody in Tj Maxx,
I forgot to get socks.
So I had to go back to the gay store,
you know.
And um,
you know,
I come walking into the store and the
same dudes behind the counter and I was
just like,
dude,
you got a,
you sell socks here,
you know,
because all he had was white socks.
I was going to sit down at church and
they were going to come up and they're
like,
ankles,
like Nikes,
socks.
I was gonna wear with like fucking wing
tips.
I wasn't going to do that.
So they actually had regular socks.
So that's what I learned at the gay
store.
They just had regular Nike socks.
But for some reason the tag on him took
a picture of it.
I got to send this,
I'm going to,
you know what,
I'm going to tweet this out or whatever.
The tag on the socks just said,
bitch,
please.
I guess woman or maybe a guy in drag
with his face all twisted up.
I got on bitch please socks by Nike,
you know,
and they fail normal.
These are made for gay feet.
But for some reason they seem to fit
mind just just fine.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
Um,
I mentioned earlier that I hadn't been
meditating and it came to a head so to
speak,
and uh,
remember when I was bitching,
updating my fucking phone and then
trying to update my laptop and there's
no one to call and I'm typing in the
right passwords and the two are not in
sync and I don't know how to do it.
I finally had a meltdown and my laptop
was closed and I took my phone and I
just fucking slammed it down like corner
first onto my laptop,
you know,
somewhere between a jab in an overhand
right.
But it was a stabbing motion and a,
I don't know what.
Then I fucking opened my laptop and the
screen was broken.
So my question I have for you guys
is not,
do I need anger management?
I know I do.
My question is,
is can people have just fix a fucking
screen?
You could do that.
It's not the hard drive.
There was no water get.
They just take that out.
It's like I got a broken windshield on
my laptop.
Can they,
can they do that?
I'm going to find out.
I'm going to find out because once again
I didn't back up anything there and I
was just really thinking back anything
up and I didn't back anything up my
phone when I dropped it in the toilet.
But do I miss any of that data,
data,
whatever the fuck you say it.
And the reality is,
is I don't,
I mean most of my pictures is taking
pictures of shit that I hate,
you know,
people's dirty feet and fucking
heartfelt photos and gay socks that say,
Bitch,
please.
I may do.
I do.
I really need to save these somewhere.
I just loved the idea that these exist
somewhere in a cloud in this,
these fucking people trying to figure
out what the shit that I take a picture
of like what can they sell me next.
K Gay socks,
coconut clusters.
I would thank you from the bottom of my
heart,
but for you,
my heart has no problem.
Okay.
This is a fat gay male with a sugar
addiction in a foot fetish.
Um.
Anyway,
so I got to read.
Oh,
by the way,
my daughter laugh for the first time
yesterday,
twice and I was on the road and I didn't
get to see,
I didn't get to hear it,
but I'm,
I'm hanging out with her all day today,
um,
other than the benefit I have to do
tonight and I'm really like psyched.
Like I came home and of course dropped
everything and picked her up and um,
she just smiled for like three minutes
straight,
which was amazing and I could tell she
was getting sleepy and I can read her
body language.
She was on the floor and she started
doing this thing like she's trying to
sit up.
I'm like,
all right,
she wants to get up and I just put her
on my lap and we were watching these
people in Maine rebuilding cabins or
some shit.
And um,
I felt there start to slump,
slumped to the right.
I knew that she was falling asleep and
she was asleep,
which as I was like,
this is a perfect time to do the
podcast,
but felt so awesome her just laying
there.
Then I stayed there for like another 20
minutes and I'm kind of breaking down
parenting into just like sections where
I know,
like I was like,
alright,
I got 18 years with her before she goes
off to college.
God willing,
so how many months is that?
I just did three of them and then the
other big countdown is the first three
years.
So the first three years all I have to
do is just fill her up with love support
and when I do lose my temper because I'm
going to,
I'm going to apologize to her and ask
her to help me work on it.
So she's not like necessarily afraid,
you know,
I just don't,
I got to kill this,
uh,
this aspect of my family tree because
everything else is pretty,
uh,
you know,
acceptable.
But I don't want to be the guy stabbing
his fucking laptop with this phone.
Freaking is cut out.
Do I do know who wants to be that
person?
And you laying on your death bed one day
and they come walking in Pekin instill,
nervous to be around you.
Just be like,
yeah,
sorry.
Sorry.
Back to,
I don't want to have that,
so I'm,
yeah,
I'm hanging out with her all day today,
reading books and the whole thing.
So I've also decided like,
all right,
so I still gotta do my two weekends a
month.
So those will be like six days.
I won't see her,
but I'll actually see her more than if I
had like a nine to five because then I
can come home and just totally focused
on her,
you know,
for the next 10 days before I go out on
the road.
So,
you know,
and every person that's apparent,
they all say it goes by so fast,
it goes by so fast.
So I just keep thinking that every
fucking time.
I'm every day.
So hopefully,
hopefully,
you know,
hopefully I don't fuck this up,
but I'm not gonna lie to you.
I know I'm a mess so I'm differently.
Uh,
you know,
the jury's out.
Hate people walk around with great debt.
I'm a great dad.
Shut the fuck up.
That's not for you to say somebody says
that to you.
You can't,
um,
you know.
Awesome.
Always awesome.
You know why?
Because I said so.
I'm alright.
Audible.
Okay,
here we go.
Get some reads here.
This is the advertising audible.
Lou Audible.
Okay.
Louis Black's new book,
the Great Louis Black,
a Lewis Black.
The rant is due is the new original
comedy series from audible channels.
Oh,
I thought it was a book.
I said it was a book.
Lewis' new book.
You can hear the latest episode for Free
Right now at audible.com/Lewis
Black.
Now,
who the fuck would want to hear a book
written by a written and read by Louis
Black.
I'm doing this.
Um,
this show is written by the fans.
Uh,
you can't.
You can rant about everything from
politics to relationships to anything
that's driving you mad by submitting
your rant to Lewis Black right now.
And listening to the rant is due for
free at audible.com/Louis
Louis Black.
For anyone that doesn't know Louis
Black,
he's a comedy hero.
A regular on the daily show.
He's got standup specials on HBO and
Comedy Central.
He's the voice of anger in inside out.
And he's got over a million fans
connecting everyday on social media.
I remember the first time I saw Louis
Black,
I saw him at the comedy cellar right
before he blew up.
He was about my age,
maybe a little younger,
about 45,
46,
and it was one of those fucking hot,
brutally hot summer days
in La.
And he came and still wearing his sport
coat and all that.
And he was just like,
miserable.
Okay.
He already walks around with a certain
level of agitation,
which I could totally relate to is.
Remember I said I walk around at a six,
so going up to 10 isn't that quick of a
ride.
So Louis came in and there was like
nobody in the fucking club.
It was like the mid nineties,
like [inaudible] 95,
96 and comedy was still dealing with the
eighties hangover,
still waiting to make another comeback.
And so he goes in there in front of like
three fucking people,
I don't know,
three tables of people,
whatever.
And I had never seen him.
And he got in there and he was legit
upset about how fucking hot it was
outside and then you combine that with
his material and his stage persona and
he got that finger going and it was
like,
I'll never forget that I was fucking
dying.
This guy when he was in front of like 11
people murdering,
like he was at Carnegie Hall.
And um,
that was just one of those great.
Jed just moved to New York and it was
just one of those great,
oh my God,
who the fuck is this guy?
How I never seen this guy.
How does everybody know who this guy is
in?
Within like three.
I was like 95,
96 and I want to say he hit around like
99.
W was quick within like by 1999,
I think he went out on the road and he
did that.
Um,
that classic comedy tour lineup.
It was him,
Mitch Hedberg and Dave attell.
Can you believe that?
That was a fucking tour.
Hey,
we're going to go out and go see comedy
tonight.
Oh yeah.
Who you seen?
I don't know.
This Guy Louis Black,
this up and coming guy,
Mitch Hedberg.
I'm trying to think of a David tell had
his show yet and I think he had
insomniac.
Maybe Mitch had his half hour up,
but um,
I didn't even get to see that fucking
talk because I was too busy slugging it
out my fucking hell.
Rooms.
I would have loved to have seen that.
Um,
so anyways,
so I'm sitting here,
Babylon and supposed to be reading a
advertise.
I'm telling stories.
All right.
Frame bridge everybody.
That's so weird.
I just shot one day on a movie and
Framingham,
Massachusetts out there on fucking off
of route nine,
I believe.
I used to do the Nixon Framingham out
there a long time ago.
Over 20 years where they go.
All right.
Frame Bridge.
Everybody.
Give your personal experience using
frame bridge.com
if applicable.
I've never used it.
It sounds like a great idea.
But I stabbed my fucking laptop in the
face.
Stabbed in the face.
I always have to say in the face,
you know what that's from.
That's from,
uh,
the great performance given by that cop
in the bathroom in reservoir dogs.
The way he,
the rhythm of the way he speaks is soap.
Like perfect cop.
I said,
buddy,
I am going to shoot you in the face.
You don't put your fucking hands in a
dashboard.
That's one of those movies when you've
seen it that many times,
like all the usual good lines that
everybody quotes out of the fucking
blue,
you know,
I'm trying to be a fucking professional.
You always got big killed,
asshole.
All those ones that everybody knows.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Bam,
Bam.
Look at them and done what I told them
not to do.
Everybody knows those lines.
But then once you want,
once you get up to like three,
400 viewings of it,
which you really can do in the summer if
you fucking put your mind to it and you
have no social life like me.
Yeah.
That's when you start going,
who the fuck is this guy playing this
cop the way he's killing this monologue?
Um,
I dunno,
I don't know why.
It just reminded me of this comedian
denny live from philly and I remember
when he was doing this white guy
denny's,
a black dude,
so he's doing this white guy and the way
he was doing the cadence and the way,
the way the guy was talking was,
you know,
that was like sort of at the height of
the fallout of the hacky white guy like
that.
He's like,
I gotta do my taxes,
like that fucking thing.
But he was actually legitimately doing a
white guy,
like an impression that I couldn't even
fucking do it,
but I could see the dude that he was
doing.
Um,
I don't know those,
those are the things that I like when I
watched and shit.
But anyways,
frame bridge,
um,
no,
no experience with Dota frame
bridge.com.
Choose your frame or let their designers
help you choose.
Upload your photo from your computer or
directly from instagram.
Preview your photo online in the frame
you choose.
Exclamation point.
This is where it's getting exciting.
Everybody can upload your photo or art.
Don't stab your laptop with your
smartphone.
No worries.
You can mail it.
You can mail it in for free.
It's affordable.
This is.
That part is totally fucking old.
People like me.
You can call up the pony express.
You can do it that way.
Uh,
the expert team at frame bridge will
custom frame your item in days,
not weeks or months.
And deliver your finished piece directly
to your door.
Ready to hang.
Frame Bridge offers a happiness
guarantee.
Uh,
their team I hate when they do shit like
that.
Are you happy?
We're just doing a follow up call with
you.
One hundred percent satisfied.
I don't think I've ever been 100 percent
satisfied about anything.
Well that Kinda goes against our team
spirit awards.
Alright,
a lie to you.
I'm 100 percent satisfied with my
fucking photo of impulse items at Tj
Maxx.
Their team gives each item personal care
and attention because meeting your
expectation is as important as meeting
their own.
Yeah,
somebody's cracking the whip over there.
Uh,
don't get stuck searching for a last
minute gift order now for mother's Day
delivery.
Go to Franklin.
That's a great idea.
Picture you and your mom,
you know she's going to love that.
This is cheapest shit.
It's perfect for all you tightwads that.
Love your mom,
but don't think she's good enough to
spend money.
This is what you do.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and use Promo
Code [inaudible] B U R,
r,
you'll save an additional 15 percent off
your first order.
Just go to frame bridge.com.
Promo Code Bar,
frame bridge.com.
Promo Code [inaudible].
All right,
here we go.
Um,
how many more of these fucking are two
more of these things.
Alright.
Oh,
blue apron,
everybody speaking and getting rid of
your man tits.
This is a good way to do it.
And ladies,
you'll,
you'll be able to keep your tits and get
rid of UCB,
which is right below,
if you know what it means between you.
Uh,
and your titties.
The ocb there.
I'm sorry,
Blue Apron.
Everybody.
See,
remember that fucking movie that was on
the CBI was just above fucking truckers.
Kris Kristofferson was,
was in it.
And uh,
Ernest Borgnine was,
was the state trooper up there in the
helicopter.
Convoy.
And I remember they were trying to get
this fucking convoy of trucks to just
stop driving.
It was like vanishing point with like
70,
72,000
fucking 18 wheelers.
They just weren't,
they weren't stopping for nothing,
man.
They were just out there and you're just
gonna keep on driving.
So these cops were trying to stop them
and they for some reason couldn't.
So now Ernest Borgnine,
you know,
sort of the go between between truckers
and cops,
like he understands them.
So there's some cut up in the elevator
going,
hey,
you fucking truckers.
This is,
this is the place where up here to
helicopter,
we really don't have a gun turret or
anything,
but we're watching you so you better be
nervous,
you know,
he's trying to make threats up there and
this fucking helicopter.
So Ernest Borgnine,
it just shakes his head.
He goes,
that ain't going to listen to that.
And he grabs the CB,
goes these truckers.
He goes,
they got a language all their own.
And then he goes to talk to them down
there.
And he goes,
this is the bear in the air.
Now I forget how you delivered that
line.
Even fucked it up.
This is the bear in the air,
like smokey the bear,
you know,
smokey the cop.
Do I have to break it down to,
you know,
that's one of the things that I can't
fucking stand.
I hate when obvious slang people feel
that they have to break it down to you.
You know what I mean?
I remember one time I saw this one man
show and the guy goes,
we were going into Maddie Hattie.
He goes,
that's Manhattan for all you white
people.
I want to be like,
oh,
I couldn't figure that one out.
It was so.
It was so slick and clever.
I mean,
you're almost saying Manhattan.
And of course it got a laugh.
White people,
they don't understand things.
Um.
All right,
let's get.
What am I on my technically in the
middle of a read here.
All right.
Blue Apron.
Yeah.
Alright.
This is about food and aprons.
Okay.
Blue aprons mission is to make
incredible home cooking accessible to
everyone.
All right?
It's about time.
Up until then,
the button tell blue apron.
Only the upper one percent were allowed
to have food prepared for them while the
rest of us will fucking nine on bushes
because blue apron ships the exact
amount of each ingredient required for
the recipe.
You better not fucking spill anything.
No,
they are reducing food waste because
it's the exact amount you bought.
Bastard,
you're going to be like a crackhead.
Crawled around a motel,
fucking floor looking for a rock.
Did the basil go under the bed?
Cooking together,
build strong family bonds,
juniors,
it's time to put in the sugar research
shows,
research it.
Research shows that Blue Apron families
cook nearly three times more often.
Those who spend a lot at restaurants or
at high end grocery stores can now spend
under $10 per person for a delicious
meal each meal.
It's a weird word.
Just realize that meal.
You guys want to have a meal,
a Neil,
you want a meal?
Each meal comes with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card and pre
portioned ingredients and can be
prepared in 40 minutes or less.
Blue aprons freshness.
Guarantee promises that every ingredient
in your delivery arrives ready to cook
or they'll make it right.
Check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/
[inaudible].
You'll love how good it feels and tastes
to create incredible home cooked meals
with blue apron set away.
That's blue apron.com/burr
blue apron.
A better way to cook.
I love that blue apron.
It was just so many different ways you
can do that line.
Read Blue Apron,
a better way to cook,
right?
Like fucking ving rhames.
We have the meats.
How great is that fucking advertising
campaign?
I've never had a desire to eat there
ever.
It's like I don't want fast food.
Roast beef.
Does anything fucking die quicker than
fucking roast beef?
I mean,
I know it's dead already.
You know,
rotting flesh is all you fucking stupid
fucking vegetarians.
Talk about like your plants not dead
already to the such dopes.
They really are.
All of them.
Every single one of them.
I put them all in one group because
that's what I do because I don't take
the time to get to know people.
Okay.
And right now it's.
I think this country needs a little more
of that,
don't you?
Right.
See,
so everyone attention comedy nerds come
to a magical place called seesaw where
new standup comedy specials debut every
month.
This month they have big Jay Oakerson
with what's your fucking deal?
A standup series featuring nothing but
crowd work.
That's funny,
man.
From big J and dozens of headlining
comics.
That's a fucking great name for a show.
What's your fucking deal?
I just picture a big Jay sitting there
on his own.
The store just looking around and shit.
Fucking deal.
Huh?
What do you do that filling up with
Cecil?
You get unlimited access to seeso
original series this next day,
late night.
A hilarious standup specials.
Binge worthy classics,
including 42 seasons of Saturday night
live.
That's crazy.
Everything,
when you want to watch the entire monty
python catalog,
the it crowd and more sign up now to
catch brand new standup specials from
the Great Nick Depaulo
from the incredible joey go.
Sorry.
I tried to do it like Michael Buffer.
Bruce Buffer.
Actually I was trying to do bruce buffer
and the new season of bigj ogre sins.
What's your fucking deal?
Or Watch your favorite sets from
comedians like Fahim Anwar Pronounced
Faheem aren't on war.
Do you know what does everybody have to
start on?
Big Jay Oakerson show.
Do you have to say what's your fucking
deal?
You got to say,
I mean it's almost like a game show,
right?
All of it higher.
You know,
this are certain things that you have to
say.
I can't think of a catchphrase from a
game show anyways.
Hey Bill,
the shows already a hit.
It's in its second season.
They don't need you fucking retooling
it.
It's like some ghosts producer.
Fair enough.
Alright.
Access CSO content from anywhere at
anytime using Ios,
android,
Roku,
apple TV,
Amazon fire,
Amazon,
fire TV.
That sounds like a bad fucking Dunno.
Vodka or Cologne or some shit.
Windows on or xbox one.
Ready for the xbox one.
Sorry.
Ready for the punchline?
I thought one ready wasn't even one of
those things.
Ready for the punchline?
Yes,
Bill,
we are.
CSO is just $399 per month.
No joke.
Three $99 per month for all the comedy
you want.
Anytime.
Anywhere.
Ad Free Ad free.
You're listening to an ad right now.
How annoying is this year?
You're free of this.
Just go to Seeso.com.
S e e s o Dot Sierra.
Echo Echo Sierra Oscar.com
right now to sign up for one month for
free with Promo Code [inaudible] at
checkout.
That's Seeso.com.
Spelled s t e s o.com.
Promote Promo Code Seeso.com.
Promo Code [inaudible].
Alright.
Not to nitpick but I would've spelled it
s e e s e o.
So when you spell it out,
you know,
two weeks.
Two SS.
Two E's.
Two O's.
See,
so cecil.
Um,
alright let's plow ahead here.
All right.
Okay.
Oh Jesus.
Boston sports.
Let's Talk Boston sports that it at that
data.
Um,
Jesus.
What a couple of fucking games those
were.
Um,
all right,
let's start with the Boston bruins.
We've lost three games straight to the
Ottawa senators.
Um,
I missed the,
I missed yesterday night's game because
I was at the memorial service,
but I definitely watched game two,
game three.
And although we had a furious got back
and [inaudible] three,
it was not enough.
I was actually in the north end.
I mean the cigar bar smoking his stogy,
hoping it was going to be a good thing.
What a fuck.
And that was a great goal though.
And overtime they'll give and go,
got to admit.
And uh,
I dunno,
I dunno if they'd just been out playing
us and they deserve it.
Now,
granted it was a shit call,
but there's going to be shit calls.
It's just going to happen.
But uh,
you know,
I don't know shit.
Call a no shit.
Call.
We've lost three games in a row.
So,
I mean,
you can only look in the mirror.
So we'll see what happens.
Um,
the excitement of the bruins making the
playoffs is quickly subsiding here.
I would like to see them win a series
and now they're,
they get their fucking backs up against
the wall.
So we'll see.
We'll see.
We'll see when game five comes up.
I imagined tomorrow.
All right.
And then the celtics.
Oh,
Jesus Celtics have been completely
exposed.
I know that that's probably been said a
thousand times.
You know what's funny is when I first
got back into the NBA,
which I got back into it because Paul
[inaudible] was coming out here and he
loves the NBA and he was staying with
me,
him and his lovely wife staying with me
and my lovely wife for like four or five
days.
And uh,
I'm a hell of a host or what a host,
what host,
right.
So I'm just like,
alright,
well,
you know,
he's coming to town.
I got to get some johnny blue.
I got to get the NBA package so he can
watch his Nixon.
I just got into the Celtics.
So I've been watching them since
December of 2015.
And my first thought when I was watching
them,
I was like,
where are we going to go with this game
plan?
Where we have this super superstar point
guard,
we live and die by the three and we
don't get any fucking rebound,
so like I don't understand how you can
win
anything
playing basketball like that,
but then here's what happened.
They did and they just kept winning and
everybody else,
it just became socially acceptable on
the hard court to fucking run down the
court with the ball.
Three people
from the other team onto the net.
Nobody on your team or maybe one guy.
It was totally acceptable to say I'm not
waiting for my other teammates and I'm
just going to launch a fucking three,
you know,
and we're up by one with like fucking
eight minutes to go like,
what are you doing?
But that just,
you know,
the same way after Jordan,
people were just like,
well I guess we don't need to feed it to
a big man.
I do.
We even need a big man,
randy,
you know.
So I was like,
all right,
I guess this is the new game.
So we ended up not only doing great this
year,
once we added Al Horford yeah,
we fucking got the number one seat and
at that point I completely forgot about
my initial reaction to the way that they
were playing.
And I was like,
alright,
I guess,
yeah,
we're the number one.
See we get an eight seat.
All right.
And after the first two games it's like,
you know,
it seems like the opposite.
Seems like they're the number one seed
and where the eight seat and I kind of
knew we were in trouble.
Uh,
I guess,
well when Charles Barkley just basically
broke our team down after the first half
of the first game going,
yeah,
you just basically you double team
Isaiah tried to make a beat the double
and then if these guys don't hit their
threes,
you know,
they're not getting any fuck.
I don't know what the hell he said,
but it's just like,
all right,
this guy's already figured this out.
Basically what I'm saying is I think
this is the first real test for Brad
Stevens,
this next game where he has to make a
drastic adjustment with the players that
he has because they figured this out
before the opening tip off and that has
led to two losses and we have not been
able to make any adjustment.
And what's fascinating about the bowls
is even though that they're an eighth
seed,
they got Rondo and they got Dwayne Wade
and Rondo's got a ring and I think
Dwayne Wade,
he's got what?
Three rings for rings.
He won one was shack and then two with
Lebron three with Lebron.
I can't remember.
I'm not a big NBA guy.
He's got at least three rings,
so there's four rings right there.
Those guys have been through it numerous
times,
so they're not afraid of the ebbs and
flows of the game.
They're not afraid of playing on the
road.
They had just totally chill and I think
that affects the rest of the team.
And then he got Butler and Lopez who
have just fucking animals,
just hitting 12 foot jump shots,
15 photos while getting all these
rebounds.
And then that fucking white dude from
Europe,
Vlade Divac Junior Jr.
He's fucking started hitting threes and
you know,
we're getting asses kicked.
So
I'll see wHat happens if you know.
But uh,
jesus christ,
I mean we were down three to one in
hockey and went down.
Oh,
to going out to chicago.
So I'm hoping.
I'm hoping.
Yeah.
Jesus.
So we don't get fucking swept.
I mean,
I dunno.
Brutal,
brutal,
brutal.
But you know,
what are you gonna do with him?
It's just a fucking game.
I realized that if the first one when
I'm watching,
you know,
isaiah thomas crying about losing his
sister was really a brutal week for that
type of shitter than Aaron Hernandez
hung himself.
Man,
that was fucking brutal.
The whole thing was brutal.
And then all those fucking jokes that
people were making like,
oh yeah,
he got hung up.
He's got an upper body injury to the
neck.
Oh,
this dumb shit.
That shit to me is always weird.
Where are you going to say,
oh,
that guy's a murderer.
He's a fucking piece of shit.
And then everybody acts like a fucking
animal when he kills himself.
Um,
of course there's people out there that
don't think,
you know,
something else happened.
It's like,
all right,
you got just got acquitted on those
other two murders and then you had a
good chance for an appeal.
You know,
you had some hope.
Um,
but I don't know who the fuck knows.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I don't necessarily agree with that or
disagree.
I have no fucking idea.
But I do know was,
I think you've already sort of a fucking
human being.
The whole thing was just sad.
It's just like,
you know,
it's just,
all these lives just fucking thrown away
over.
Nothing.
Granted,
you know,
obviously he pulled the fucking trigger
and everything like that,
but still I don't take any sort of a.
I don't know,
honeStly,
I didn't get that.
I was just like,
ugh.
It was just.
Yeah,
it's one of those thIngs you just from
front to back,
you just wish it didn't happen.
And everybody's like,
hey,
here's my fucking obvious joke.
Um,
so anyway.
Oh god,
am I really gonna be talking about
fucking him killing himself?
Is that how I'm going to end this
podcast?
How long has it has been?
Forty three minutes.
Well,
you know what?
I'm in overtime.
All right,
let's end up on something positive
tonight.
Of course I'm working tonight and this
fucking band that I've been wanting to
see because their drummers amazing.
I don't have his name in front of me.
I should have it,
but I don't spend called russian
circles.
Is playing,
um,
is playing at the uh,
oh,
for fuck sakes.
What's the name of the fucking day?
Every goddamn theater begins with a p
out here.
Hey,
I got to hit pause.
I gotta make sure you have this
information hung.
Hang on the palladium.
Fuck,
get tickets.
Paramont the pompadour,
the fucking palladium.
Actually,
that's where richard pryor tape a live
on the sunset strip.
So I was introduced to this Band.
They played this song,
harper louis live and uh,
their drummer absolutely fucking blew me
away with his,
um,
Just how solid
his,
his beats were and then his use of
dynamiCs.
It's just on a whole other fucking
level,
which I really think is a lost art.
Um,
but they're playIng tonight at 6:30
PM and I wish I could go,
but I got a fucking goddamn benefit so I
can't make it,
but I'll post that clip of the band
playing that song.
Harper louis.
It's the live version and just the way,
you know,
it just starts off with the drum beat
that he's playing and he's playing it,
you know,
it gradually builds in intensity,
gets louder and louder and then,
uh,
then when they go into that on,
it's an instrumental band.
I don't know how to say versus chorus.
I don't know what the fuck they're
doing,
but just absolutely blew me away.
If you've got nothing to do tonight,
you want to see a killer band,
go down and get a couple of tickets to
that.
I guarantee you have a great time.
Um,
all right,
that is the podcast.
I'm it,
I guess because it's 4:20
like weed man,
I guess a andrew's going to be giving
you guys some extra clips.
It's going to be a little bit longer and
uh,
and that is it.
And it was an honor to be at charlie
murphy's memorial service.
It was an honor to know that guy and I
want to thank,
uh,
everybody who spoke that night last
night,
the,
the way that they sent that guy off,
it was just like it was,
it just was a level of greatness in the
performances that I saw from the
comedians that went up and spoke and um,
charlie was one of the greats,
you know,
and it was just,
it was such a perfect send off and I'm
really glad that I was able to be there
and witness it.
All right,
sO that's it.
I'll let you fucking concept a great
weekend and enjoy this music and some,
some clips from a podcast recorded
monday or a thursday gone by.